francia conmemora el día de la victoria
en los actos de homenaje estuvo presente
el recién posesionado jefe de estado
francés emmanuel macrón las actividades
comenzaron con una ofrenda ante la
estatua del general y ex presidente
charles de gaulle quien dirigió la
resistencia francesa contra la alemania
nazi
como es costumbre el mandatario se
dirigió al arco del triunfo donde rindió
homenaje a la bandera francesa y al
soldado desconocido y aunque no
pronunció discurso si se pronunció en
las redes sociales
77 años después no podemos olvidar a
nuestros héroes aquellas mujeres y
hombres que lucharon para poner fin a la
guerra en europa permanezcamos unidos
como europeos y trabajemos para
restaurar la paz en nuestro continente
este año la conmemoración tuvo lugar en
medio de la invasión de rusia ucrania un
enfrentamiento militar que por su escala
muchos observadores consideran sin
precedente en europa desde la segunda
guerra mundial
en este sentido también se pronunció el
canciller alemán olaf scholz de este
berlinés fue playing
ya es mucho más doloroso presenciar que
77 años después del fin de la segunda
guerra mundial una vez más la fuerza
bruta está quebrantando la paz y la ley
en cuanto a europa pero como el ejército
de rusia está matando hombres mujeres y
niños en ucrania reduciendo ciudades a
escombros y cenizas e incluso atacan a
los que usen las eps fernando por su
parte vladimir selenski público desde la
semidestruida ciudad devoró dianca un
vídeo en el que denuncia un paralelo
entre la invasión nazi de los años 40 y
la invasión de hoy la previa el tren
mariupol durante dos años de ocupación
los nazis mataron a 10.000 personas en
dos meses de ocupación los rusos han
matado a 20 mil décadas después de la
segunda guerra la oscuridad ha retornado
a ucrania y se volvió blanco y negro de
nuevo el mal ha retornado de nuevo en un
uniforme diferente con otros eslóganes
pero con el mismo propósito
así se conmemora este 8 de mayo la
derrota de alemania en 1945 y hay gran
expectativa por la conmemoración en
moscú que como es tradición
un día después el 9 de mayo